i just can't decide
should i play around a golf today well
let's use this decision tree
to make the decision
so first off do i have
the time
if i don't
well then that's an easy decision
no golf
but let's say i do
second decision point is it
sunny today
if there's sun
then i don't care about any other factor
playing golf
if there's no sun let's go down to the
next level well do i have my clubs with
me do i have them handy
if i do not
then i'm not going to bother playing if
it's not sunny
if i do
then
i absolutely will
the decision tree here is an example of
a classification problem where the class
labels are golf yes and golf no
and while they're helpful decision trees
they can now be prone to problems things
like bias and overfitting but that is
where something called
random
forest
comes in to play
random forest is a type of machine
learning model that uses an ensemble of
decision trees to make its predictions
and why do we call it random forest well
the reason is because it's actually
built by taking a random sample of my
data and then building an ongoing series
of decision trees on those subsets so
we're essentially creating a whole bunch
of decision trees
together
and
those give us a larger model or group
look the chances are that other people
have built different and maybe better
decision trees to answer the same
question
maybe those trees consider things like
the time of day which i didn't consider
or the difficulty of the course
the more decision trees that i use with
different criteria the better my random
forest will perform because it's
essentially increasing my prediction
accuracy and if one or two of these
smaller decision trees are not relevant
on a certain day
well we just ignore them
one of the primary benefits of random
forest is that it can help reduce
overfitting
and this occurs when your model starts
to memorize the data rather than trying
to generalize for making predictions on
future data essentially it helps me get
around the limitations of my data which
might not be fully representative of all
golfers or all the best features in my
model
it can also help reduce something else
and that's bias
bias can occur when there is a certain
degree of error introduced into the
model bias occurs when you're not evenly
splitting your instant space during
training so instead of seeing all of the
data points you might see only half
because of how you set your model up
now to set up a random forest you will
set some parameters
we have parameters for node
size
we have parameters for number of trees
and we also have parameters for
number of features
and it can be challenging at first
because you'll want to use a lot of
trees like as many as you can to get the
best predictive accuracy but you don't
want so many trees that will take you a
long time to train the model and use a
lot of memory space but once you've set
up these parameters you'll use a random
forest model to make predictions on your
test data and you can even segment or
slice your results by different criteria
maybe you want to know how your random
forest does on certain types of golf
courses or how it performs during
different times of day
random forest is pretty popular among
data science professionals and with good
reason it can be extremely helpful in
all sorts of classification problems in
finance for example
it can be used to predict the
likelihood of a default
in a medical
diagnosis
it can be used to predict prognosis or
survival rates depending on treatment
options and in
economics it can be
used to sort of help understand whether
a policy is effective or ineffective
so what do you think should i play golf
today
well the sum of all my random forest
decision trees say
yes i'll see you out on the course
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching
you